- You know what's so funny?
That's probably the most, uh, I've had
in my stomach in a long time in a rant.
(upbeat music)
- [Woman] He's like forward thinking.
He's not scared to speak his mind.
- And it's practical.
- [Woman] It's totally practical.
- That's the thing that,
like, that's the part
I will never win because
of my gift of gab.
It hides the level of
practicality that I'm speaking to.
This is real now.
- [Woman] It's completely real now.
I think that you're
basically, this is what
you had to say, and I hope that--
- I want--
- [Woman] I hope the P&G'ers--
- It's a selfless execution.
- [Woman] Absolutely.
- Because my ambition is to buy brands
that companies like this ruin,
buy them on a nickel on the
dollar, and resurrect them.
So, I just can't buy them all,
so might as well do good along the way.
- [Man] I'm running a small startup.
It's like--
- It's a totally different point, right?
- [Man] It's like your
head, you're going all this,
it's like you don't tolerate things
that you would've at bigger companies.
- 100%, you can't afford to.
- [Man] Yeah.
- Yeah, thanks for saying hello, yeah.
- [Man] Thank you, yeah.
- The vlog, it's gonna be a short episode
mainly cause D-Rock overslept,
and because we took a connecting red-eye
from LA, to Chicago, to here in Cincinnati
where I just gave a key note.
To be very frank, maybe
it's because my good friend
Craig, let's show Craig,
maybe because of his words,
and he's always very straight but kind,
or maybe just, you know,
you have these talks.
They're moments in time.
Something really great
just happened on stage.
I would say that what it was was it's
a moment that I would say synthesizes,
confirms, reinforces, puts
the bow on this thesis
that I'm living on an every day basis,
and i just fucking know I'm right.
I don't know what else to say.
I just know I'm right,
and I know that every day
that passes, more good is
gonna be happening for me.
The amount of money that
I'm leaving on the table
the last seven years, for
the historical brand equity
of being correct, is enormous.
This is a subtlety that I
don't talk to you about,
don't talk about in general.
It's because I'm not cashing
in on all the opportunities
because I'm trying to spend
time on doing a talk like this
that just took up my whole day
because the inefficiencies
of LA, Cincinnati,
and New York, but the impact is greater
in the word of mouth of
this collective audience
over a four to five year macro.
So many people, so many
of you are scrutinizing
how to maximize more views, more likes,
more engagement, more ad
sense pre-roll in your thing,
more sales, more t-shirt
sales, more speaking fees,
short term financial.
Please, please pay
attention to what I'm doing
which is make the financial
you need to survive,
to live, and maybe to get
that one or two things
you need a year to get
your nuts off and be happy,
a trip here, a trip there,
but then take all those
other dollar opportunities, or dollars,
and reinvest them into where you're going.
I reinvest them in content creation,
in distribution of my thoughts,
in pontificating my truths,
and giving away my best value to you
and anybody who's willing to consume it
with the hopes and
thoughts that the karma,
and the realities of those
truths in a 10 year window,
create the opportunities
for me to trade on
in the future.
Please, please, please pay
attention to what I'm doing
I'm super empathetic.
I only deploy empathy.
It doesn't make it right, though.
And, there's something clearly happening.
It's macro data.
The brands are losing.
- [Woman In Gray] Yeah, they're losing.
- It's real.
97%, this is not you, all of them.
- [Woman In Gray] No, it's
all brands are losing.
- All of them, 97% Fortune
500 CPG brands declined.
That's absurd.
- [Woman In Gray] It is absurd.
- It's the over investment
in TVC and programmatic
digital banners.
That's really what it is.
There's a lot going on.
- Yeah, we've been talking
about it the whole conference.
- Online dating, Uber,
Airbnb, this is real stuff.
- [Woman In Gray] It's real, I know.
- Like, it's real.
It's not coming, it's here.
- [Woman In Gray] No, and
Gen Z and millennials,
if you look at actually
what they grew up with--
- What about you?
- [Woman In Gray] Yeah, what about me?
We even use Uber.
We Ubered last night.
- Thank you.
How easy is it to get to
you on page 147 of Vogue.
you to a banner pop-up ad.
How easy is it?
It's not.
It's not where your attention is.
Not your actual attention,
not potential attention.
It's just real.
- [Man] I mean, you see companies like,
I mean the one invested
the catalog with Sears,
and where is Sears today?
- That's right my friend.
- [Man] So, you start looking at history.
If you don't change--
- You will die.
- [Man] Congratulations.
- Thank you.
- [Man] Thank you so having us.
- Thank you for listening.
Hey, guys.
I'm gonna try and do this more often
when I'm lucky enough if D-Rock's with me.
Just tried something new
where I posted A, B, C, or D
on Twitter where I'm gonna get feedback.
I have four videos I'm sitting on.
Instead of me kind of
arbitrarily looking at
what the team's chopping up
through our conversations,
I'm gonna start using Twitter a little bit
in a kind of like 1, 2,
3, or 4, A, B, C, or D,
post the videos up, see
what the feedback is,
and then go and distribute
it in the other channels.
Sometimes we, I'm trading
on the arbitrary nature
of what I'm feeling,
which often does well,
but there's so many opportunities
to do creative things
so it's a new creative pillar for Twitter.
Make sure you follow me there.
Here's the new reason why.
You get to see almost everything.
That allows me to use it
as a siphoning mechanism
to what I then put on some
of the other platforms.
You know, try what I'm
doing, do what I'm doing
not what I'm saying.
Here's me in real time,
innovating, trying something new,
four videos in a row, bang, bang, bang,
still trying to even post,
and then looking up the feedback.
Let's see what happens.
Cool.
Instagram's a really interesting platform.
You should go look at my
trainer, Jordan Syatt.
He's so knowledgeable.
I was like, bro, you're
sitting on knowledge.
Put it out.
So, then he started making
content that was just valuable,
like breaking down things
and teaching people.
Then miraculously, he
went from 4,000 to 250,000
followers in nine months.
Why?
Because he listened to the other things
that I told him which is
Instagram's about hashtags
if nobody's following you.
Do not post anything on Instagram
without your first comment
being 15, 20 hashtags
because hashtag is the
currency inside Instagram.
He got disciplined, put out content
that was valuable to people, and then also
put 30 hashtags.
Then, slowly but surely,
people started discovering him,
and he had something of value to them.
This is value exchange.
The reason I've won for the last 20 years,
and for the rest of my life in business,
I'm trying to give the best value,
and that is leverage for
me to get what I want.
51-49.
I'm gonna give you more than I ask,
and that's why I get plenty.
Thank you, Craig.
I don't know if you've heard about the,
I got it, I got it.
Here you go, man.
Thank you.
- Oh, thank you, I appreciate it.
- I don't know if you've
heard about the hottest
super hero in the game.
- The hottest super hero?
- Yeah, the hottest
super hero in the game.
Do you know who it is?
- [Craig] Who's that?
- That is this incredible super hero
called Airport Gary.
You're gonna watch as he
transforms into it right now.
Yes.
I go from normal business man
to entrepreneurial super hero.
Airport Gary.
D-Rock, this is your
favorite part of every vlog.
- [D-Rock] Yeah.
- I have music now.
- This is another day in the life.
(laughs)
- Oh, you're--
- We're on Delta.
- You guys are on Delta?
- Yeah.
- And, I'm on what?
- [Man] United.
- Okay, well, I'm wrapping up here.
Thank you.
How are you.
- Very well.
I enjoyed it.
- [Gary] Thank you so much.
- Thoughts for the ride home.
- [Craig] I'll make sure they hold that.
- [Gary] It's very real.
- If brands can make it's products
and struggle, but manage
to make it, I guess.
I don't know.
You've just got to start
living old school today.
- [Gary] It's systematic in the way
that we're rewarding
people and their behavior.
- No, I get that.
- [Gary] It's just very big.
(upbeat music)
- Way better than Batman.